Homeland Security bill is ratified after
eight years.
British borders.
It will remain closed.
The deportation of illegal immigrants
will continue.
Good morning our lead story.
The world was stunned today by the
desert,
Diego,
Ricardo,
the youngest person on the planet,
maybe Diego was stabbed outside of bar
and what?
Osiris.
Here we are,
first of all,
funds will Korans.
Children of men is a shot of an audience
getting information about the state of
things in the same way that we do
through the media.
You may have missed it,
but Korans fundamental motif of
contrasting foreground and background
has already been established through the
media before this shot even begins.
Let's back up on the deportation of
illegal immigrants will continue.
Good morning our lead story like
everyone else.
The media prioritizes information based
on its values.
So much attention is paid to the
foreground to the lead story that the
background can go by without much
notice.
The lead story of children of men is the
story of feel in a future world nearing
its end,
because women have lost the ability to
have children.
Theo and apathetic government bureaucrat
returns to his roots as a political
activist after he sees that there is
still hope left for humanity.
The film plays as an exciting action
thriller,
as Leo helps the pregnant key get to
safety with the human project,
but as the plot moves along it's linear
path.
Following Theo,
the camera repeatedly becomes
preoccupied with what's going on in the
background,
and this is a technique that Koran has
used in the past and it makes for an
interesting effect.
As in thousands of other films we
experienced the world through the eyes
of the main character.
This process of identification is
automatic and strong,
so strong that we can even be made to
sympathize with people who we would
otherwise identify as bad or evil.
So when the camera actively breaks that
identification and shows us imagery,
the lead character doesn't see or notice
were made forcefully aware in a purely
visual way of the perspective of the
film itself.
In children of men.
That perspective is absorbed by the
background,
by a bleak great winter break.
The only country in the world still
under stable government control.
This background scene always at a side
angle probes and investigates the
conditions of that stability and whether
or not it's worth what sacrificed to
have it,
though it's dressed up with the few
futuristic flourishes the World Koran
presents to us is a reflection of our
own.
The grim combination of nationalistic,
xenophobic politics and late capitalist
consumerism isn't something that we have
to imagine when Mexico sends its people,
they're not sending best.
They're bringing drugs,
they're bringing crime.
They're rapists.
In 2006.
When this film was made only five years
after nine slash 11,
and at the height of the war on terror,
this was,
and in many ways still is the state of
things.
Thousands of migrants and refugees from
the war torn and Middle East and Africa.
A rude awakening awaits in countries
that are moving to close their doors.
And there's another background to a
figurative background of cultural
reference.
For example,
when key first reveals her pregnancy,
she stands in a posture reminiscent of
Botticelli's birth of Venus.
One of the many references in this film
to maternity,
Jasper and Miriam both recite,
teach.
We're calling both the pawnee shots and
ts Elliot's the wasteland,
which is a major source of inspiration
for an infertile world that's lost its
way outside Theo's cousins,
arc of arts.
A pig floats above the old battersea
power station and overt reference to
pink floyd's album animals.
A concept album loosely based on George
Orwell's animal farm itself,
a satirical indictment of authoritarian
socialism or Stalinism.
Indeed,
there's a lot included in the arc of art
scene.
Here's a banksy.
Here's Michelangelo's David,
because those guarantee TCA
significantly framing theo in the
realities of war and underneath it all
plays King Crimson's,
progressive rock anthem to the court of
the Crimson King,
blending the sacred and the profane,
but Korans referencing becomes more
potent as the inter texts layer and
connect.
Take this shot here at utilizes nearly
all the techniques I've mentioned so
far.
You have the lead story moving again
towards its destination at the sea,
but the camera,
it leaves them for a moment to focus on
this mother,
cradling her dead son.
The most immediate citation here is to
Michelangelo's famous sculpture,
La,
PA,
Ta,
which Nigel mentioned earlier in the
film.
Good luck top smashed up before we got
back,
and that sculpture at Mary holds the
crucified Jesus in her arms,
questioning the cruelty of men.
The image also evokes guernica also
shown earlier in the film a much more
modern meditation on the horrors of war,
and Oran has said in interviews that the
inspiration for this image came from a
photograph out of the Balkan wars
itself,
a referenced to Michelangelo's work,
whereas the arc of arts shows are
extracted in,
placed in an ivory tower.
Koran puts art back on the ground where
it belongs and brings it alive within a
number of contexts,
ancient and current,
and most importantly as a background for
the main story,
there is an absurd paradox that sits at
the center of our modern world.
While capital itself knows no borders,
people and nations struggling to find
their identities have sought repeatedly
to tighten their borders and restrict
people's from crossing them.
What's more,
these refugees are increasingly
displaced by the militaristic medley of
neoconservative regimes and the
worsening climate,
a result of the unchecked expansion of
capitalists enterprises in children of
men as in our own world.
All of these things are intimately
connected and yet for each of us
individually,
it's hard to see anything but the
foreground,
the lead story.
That's why the roving curious
preoccupations of Koran's camera are
more than just a site.
By providing a disinterested break from
identification,
they achieved something.
We just can't in our own lives.
They let us see the world bear naked,
stripped for a moment of subjectivity.
This is the radical political potential
of cinema.
We can all keep to our main stories.
If we want little worlds,
sooner or later,
the background is going to come from.
Wow,
everybody.
Thanks for watching.
I just got some awesome nerd writer
stickers delivered that are now
available on my patrion page.
You can get them by clicking right in
the middle of the screen right here or
in the description.
They are two stickers for $3,
one payment.
Boom.
You get them set.
Obviously.
I hope you continue to pledge after
that.
They're awesome for laptops and
backpacks and lunchboxes,
whenever you put stickers on their
available.
Now my patrion page and a Patriot is
what keeps the nerd writer alive and
going,
and the big goal is to get that Patriot
to a thousand dollars per video.
So thank you so much for helping me get
there and making this possible.
This content is for you guys.
See you next Wednesday.